couldn't think of a better way to end my
visit than performing at Sydney's
historic State Theatre I brought along
three of my good friends from the
basic-cable band plus I was joined by
three hilarious Australian comedians
Steen Roscoe polos Becky Lucas and re
Snickle so you're so cheerful
this guy was talking to me was like yeah
yeah we got no ozone layer we got and I
thought why is he saying it like it's my
birthday what's your favourite cereal
what's the cereal you love it wait what
we do this guy out there yelled like a
caveman who'd been shot duck back what
it's er just that guy who's yelling what
is it
you coming safe
what is it again just you no one else
wait beaks with pigs and what's it made
of wait
should've gone to Melbourne as you're
just screwing with the rest of the earth
I have a company about me what's that
cinnamon cracker wait well why don't you
say cinema cracker wait gotcha yeah now
to be fair to each song it's an even
chance here in light blue you shook me
all night long by acha daca and then in
yellow Skippy the bush kangaroo
[Music]
why do you want Skippy the bush
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anyone here with the guts to come up
here and try and sing like that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you used you have lyrics right here
they're right here you're like skin bees
give me that's so American sing the
national anthem
[Music]
[Applause]